all right let's check in with rocky she
is on a first-class flight through the
bellagio's conservatory's new spring
display so gorgeous there rocky
[Music]
it is gorgeous and as you said a first
class fight because only first class
flights the runway is the sky itself
okay so let's head on to our flight in
the hot air balloon jessica tell us
where we are right now and where we're
headed
so we are walking on air this is our
walking on air balloon this is our
center east bed and it has 15 000 roses
and that's the story of this bed so
everything about this bed is
actual airships that were retired air
airships that we
made into this beautiful balloon we have
real altimeters
in it and then we have our led walkway
clouds that you walk into
our main bed is called up up and away we
have four balloons on there one's a
zeppelin that has a waterfall coming out
of it one's a sand castle balloon one
one of them is our rose princess balloon
and then let's move over to the peacock
we have one more minute i really want to
make sure we show them this one yep so
we have a beautiful peacock bed um that
has purples and blues and there's just
so many special unique things to see
here that you have to come out and check
it out it's right off the main lobby
really easy to get to it takes so much
effort in the community to put them
together and i would just love for you
guys to come visit absolutely and last
but not least i have to point out this
one over here the yellow right behind
you lance turn around yeah okay do you
notice some high fashion versace vibes
going on here it's so cute yes this one
this one is definitely everything was
themed around the 2022 international
like colors and runway and this one's
our
our yellow bed has daffodils and finches
and just when you walk in here you get
the lavender wood scent and so much
aromatic stuff and you have to come at
night because we have a new lighting
system and you can see a whole different
experience imagine these balloons lit up
at night this is an incredible display
it has to be one of my favorites and the
music
is on point the music is a point thank
you jessica it's here until may 14th so
come by i'll send it back to you